Pursue what is meaningful,
not was this expedient,
uh,
you,
you write in the book,
there is no faith and no courage and no
sacrifice in doing what is expedient.
Why do you say to those of viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful?
Well,
the first thing I would say is,
well,
you shouldn't be afraid of taking risks
and pursuing something meaningful,
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are.
If it's making you miserable,
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that you get
to have any,
any permanent security outside of your
ability to contend and adapt.
It's the same issue with children.
It's like you're paying a price by
sitting there being miserable and you
might say,
well,
the devil I know is better than the one
I don't.
It's like,
don't be so sure of that.
The clock is ticking and if you're
miserable in your job now and you change
nothing in five years,
you'll be much more miserable and you'll
be a lot older.
But this is the luxury to pursue what is
meaningful.
Our viewers have worked with this.
They have children,
they have payments in loans.
It's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources.
Well,
I don't think.
I don't remember.
Now I'm not talking about what makes you
happy.
It's a luxury to pursue what makes you
It's a moral obligation to pursue what
you find meaningful and that doesn't
mean it's easy.
It might require sacrifice.
If you need to change your job to,
let's say you have a family and children
and a mortgage,
you have responsibilities.
You've already picked up those
responsibilities.
You don't just get to walk away Scott
Free and say,
well,
I don't like my job.
I quit.
That's no strategy.
But what you might have to do is you
think,
well,
this job is killing my soul or right?
So what do I have to do about that?
Well,
I have to look for another job while no
one wants to hire me.
It's like,
okay,
maybe you need to educate yourself more.
Maybe you need to update your,
your curriculum,
veto,
your resume.
Maybe you need to overcome your fear of
being interviewed.
Maybe you need to sharpen your social
skills like you.
You have to think about these things
strategically.
If you're going to switch careers,
you have to do it like an intelligent,
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of,
of,
of effort to do properly.
When you say pursue something
meaningful,
is it important to have a vocation?
I think it's more important to to have a
an ethos and ethic,
so I have a program,
for example,
called the future authoring program,
which is a writing program that enables
people to develop a vision for their
life and then to develop a strategy and
so it's based on the idea.
Imagine that and it's an extension of
the ideas in the book or at least
something along the same lines.
The first thing that you want to do is
figure out.
Imagine you were taking care of yourself
like you were someone you cared for,
which is rule number two,
by the way,
essentially.
Then you should figure out,
well,
if you could have what you needed and
wanted,
what would it be?
What sort of friends would you have?
What would your family relationships
look like?
How would you conduct yourself with your
children?
How would you educate yourself?
You need to think through how it is that
your life could be properly arranged if
you had that ability and then you can
name it that,
and the funny thing is is that if you do
positive goal of that sort and work
towards it,
you will move towards it.
The goal will change because you'll
learn things along the way,
but I mean I've.
I've dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
set a goal.
We develop a vision and work towards it
and it,
it,
things inevitably get better for people.
So it's not a luxury.
It's,
it's difficult.
It's a moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness.
It's,
it's not.
The pursuit isn't for happiness.
It's a moral responsibility to push you.
What is meaningful.
Absolutely.